انتصارا لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
يتعرض للعدوان والحصار في قطاع غزه نفذت
القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
بعون الله تعالى عمليه استهداف لسفينه
غرافيا كانت متجهه الى موانئ فلسطين
المحتله وذلك بعدد من الصواريخ البحريه
المناسبه وكانت الاصابه مباشره وجاءت
عمليه الاستهداف
بعد رفض طاقم السفينه النداءات التحذيريه
منها الرسائل التحذيريه الناريه ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في تنفيذ قرار منع
الملاحه الاسرائيليه او المرتبطه بالعدو
الاسرائيلي في البحرين الاحمر والعربي حتى
وقف العدوان ورفع الحصار على الشعب
الفلسطيني الصامد في قطاع غزه ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في اتخاذ كافه
الاجراءات الدفاعيه
والهجوميه ضمن حق الدفاع المشروع عن اليمن
العزيز وتاكيدا على استمرار التضامن
العملي مع الشعب الفلسطيني المظلوم والله
حسبنا ونعم الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم النصير
عاش اليمن حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمن
ولكل احرار الامه صنعاء الخامس من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق لل 16 من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه